bonsoir michel serrault vous êtes donc
le parrain de cette émission puisque
c'est toujours venu très régulièrement
nous soutenir à une époque où l'émission
était moins c4 on paie comme vous le
faites
oui c'est normal non c'est vrai ça qu'un
jeu j'aime bien qu'à chauny et vous nous
avez vous nous avez vraiment vraiment
aidé au début quand même parce que vous
étiez d'accord je vous ai été c'est vrai
mais parce que je vous aime bien oui ah
oui bien sûr des dorices que les deux
clowns de service sont là ça ira bien
sûr ils vont venir leur donner un tesson
nerfs santé perd il échappera pas vous
faites quoi en ce moment où michel
eeckhout et des stages se sait pas c'est
pas une idée avoue la de ses moustaches
comme ça c'est passé les miennes ou les
années votre seul énoncé les moustaches
en principe ça peut ressembler à
dominici ah oui voilà parce que je
tourne pour la télévision
deux épisodes sur la sphère dominici
totalement là on en est à peu près la
moitié autour d'une belle moustache à la
manière de celui que tu essaies le vieux
que tu as écouté
écoutez qu'est ce que tu veux vous dire
des cas regardez les visuels sauver tout
mais non mais je pour l'instant je ne
peux rien dire
en fait si je vais vous dire la vérité
j'ai accepté de jouer le personnage mais
je dis je vous préviens je joue non
coupable voilà d'accès non ça
m'intéresse pas donc on saura pas alors
vous verrez c'est pas à moi de juger
d'accord vous aurez tout en mois vous
verrez les vous verrez des
interrogatoires vous verrez le projet
vous verrez tout et vous jugerez très
bien aller les moustaches c'est dominici
les lunettes ce qui alors ça c'est mes
lunettes mais là je les enlève ses
lunettes
alors michel ce que je vous propose
c'est qu'on voit maintenant un best of
de vos meilleurs moments dans cette
émission vous attend pour vous avez
nommés tous les gens qui sont là oui et
je vous remercie parce que je n'ai pas
d'ennemis et je faisais très attention
le prix offert il ya deux ou trois yeux
un bateau aussi mais ils sont pas là
donc très heureux bravo vous avez bien
retenu l'action merci michel on qu'on
voit les meilleurs moments passés sur ce
plateau avec michel serrault replay m'en
voulait pas assumer
mais pour sa part fait état d un artiste
qui sort qu'à la différence de moi moi
j'ai pas les lunettes de zaza napoli
landed dont je parle je me teste
magnifique il a un charme extraordinaire
vous savez que je sais des
considérations vous plaisait beaucoup à
ma femme et moi et toi tout plat beau
lui aussi n'a aucune vie sexuelle par
exemple si on en avait déjà parlé tous
nouvelle m'a dit ça n'a jamais été mon
on habite un film magnifique
en plus de leur écoute et progiciels
j'avais c'est comme la tarte à la crème
là il faut pas mettre trop de g
parce que si vous insistez alors là je
me force paiement stop stop vous êtes
toujours le bienvenu ici d'autant plus
aujourd'hui que c'est votre anniversaire
donc je vous dis bon anniversaire
mais vous êtes au courant de tout de
tout aujourd'hui alors est ce que vous
dites que l'avenir non encore défini non
non ça tourne encore attendus c'est une
histoire d'une batterie de cuisine c'est
à dire qu'il avait tout à fait l'idée
des casseroles c'était clair en cuivre
etc et se changer avant de couper les
chaînes ils vont nous moi je m'en fous
mais elle chante mais continue et moi
j'ai inventé en cuivre et un pot de
terre qu'elle sur la table voilà c'était
les meilleurs moments de michel serrault
dans cette émission alors avec nous il y
avait qu un bon soir série daniel
auteuil philippe tesson vous regardez
les autres et de gauche claude oui je
suis un regard de ce soft que j'ai raté
l'autre fois les la critique de jérôme
béglé l'envoyer grand bien
d'autoportraits vote chez léo cher
l'important c'est qu'il est dit du bien
mais j'espère que tu bien que du bien
que vous allez venir avoir parlé très
sérieusement
daniel vous êtes venus la dernière fois
c'était pour le film
le maillon très beau film zéro moi je
dis ça monsieur les bûchers les vues
récemment et c'est vrai que le ch était
j'avais des activités qui me prenaient
en dehors de la france et j'ai pas vu le
film et que j'ai lu récemment baillot
c'est un tout tu m'as dit tout à l'heure
il paraît qu'en italien en est
formidable j'ai les boules italien on
est en expert bien du talent et moi
j'aimerais jouer plus je jouais quand l
italien mais vous pas reparti tournée en
italie
oui je suis rapide il a demandé l'exil
c'est dire si j'ai voté non non mais
c'est à dire qu'il se passe aussi des
choses intéressantes en italie quand
vous l'avez choisi pour ugolin vous vous
saviez qu'il pouvait avoir l'accent
comme ça qu'ils étaient d'avignon et qui
pouvaient avoir cet accent ah oui bien
sûr c'est parce que j'ai su qu'il était
d'avignon que je les appelais et qu'il a
était arrivé aussitôt parce qu'au départ
c'était pas évident ce que tu veux dire
par là vous n'avez pas deviné qu'il
était d'avis c'est ça ouais ça veut dire
que n'importe quel avignonnais sont là
tout à fait alors tout à l'heure ce
héros me demandez si vous étiez là il
m'a dit ce sont là les deux j'ai parlé
tout nu et comme j'adore les clous de
l'autre en tout cas l'autre banane
rabbani dans la bête sont nés d'un
bonnet rouge
mais c'est pas le c'est pas plutôt le
vin non non non non non non on her son
est très puritain très sobre à bord
pendant ces critiques puisqu'il en fait
on en fait beaucoup
alors on a posé des questions pour la
millième berry a répondu c'est bien vous
êtes très disciplinés consciencieux oui
voilà alors vous a demandé votre livre
votre film pièce de théâtre votre
chanson votre événement préférez donc le
difc chambre bleue sinon oui que je bois
pas je ne sais pas je les lui récemment
c'est le titre qui m'est venue en
mémoire ouais c'est un très beau livre
j'ai j'aime bien la façon dont il est
des cons structure et puis c'est i -
c'est cette cette histoire d'amour
passionnelle sexuelles non c'est un très
beau livre est alors le film c'est
gladiator de ridley scott c'est quand
même très bizarre non non c'est parce
que j'ai su retourner le voir avec un de
mes fiches
j'aime le cinéma populaire et j'avoue
que gladiator j'ai adoré quoi ouais je
préfère ne pas m'ennuyer aussi le
théâtre le nouveau testament de sacha
guitry on en comprend et et la chanson
renault wind renault pourquoi pas oui
oui j'aime beaucoup renault et vous
auteuil c'est quoi votre livre préféré
mon livre préféré ces autoportraits non
ce que je veux dire c'est que le
questionnaire portait sur ces cinq
dernières années
oui et ces cinq dernières années j'ai
beaucoup regardé votre émission or il se
trouve que vous avez vu lu entendu pour
moi des milliers de choses c'est pour ça
et que c'est pour ça que vous êtes là
c'est pour ça que ça nous soulage on
n'est pas obligé d'aller voir ni
entendre pour qu'on aille voir écouter
ou ans il faut vraiment que vous soyez
vachement beau tiens ça vous arrive et
c'est pour ça qu'on dit va donc le livre
le lait auto portrait autoportrait autre
autoportrait pour que pour des raisons
éthiques sur hugo la direction effective
parce que
parce que claude a arrive à faire
quelque chose de très beau avec avec la
vie enfin il arrive à faire de la
littérature et à dépasser l'anecdote est
à nous entraîner comme ça dans d'un dans
ses pages sais pas mais tous les gens
qui l'ont lu on dit ça on dit que c'est
pas simplement des mémoires ou des
anecdotes mais que c'est vraiment des
allitérations et et ratures bien sûr
c'est ce que j'ai essayé de faire
ouais parce que raconter ma vie les
mémoires ça m'intéressait pas beaucoup
ce que l'ambition que j'avais c'était de
faire un livre
ouais non mais c'est vrai que il ya un
style absolument cinglant c'est très
limpide c'est très simple il ya un
mélange du passé du présent et on a la
vie d'un type absolument fascinant qui
se déroule qui se met vraiment à poil
devant vous avec une certaine
délectation je dois dire il s'invente
pas que délectation dans la cruauté j'ai
beaucoup regardé michael youn michael
youn à pois le matin voilà donc c'est le
morning live de claude berri
l'autoportrait quoi ouais elle en parle
comme d'un film japonais était très
bonne et très bonne ce joyau des chicago
donc elle parle devait parler de chicago
et puis il a dit non finalement je vais
pas vous en parler mais il ya un film
tadjik en noir et blanc en scope 3h30 et
celui-là il est bien votre film préféré
alors c'est quoi au fils préféré y tous
les films c'est peut-être les parapluies
de cherbourg 1
peut-être voilà s'il fallait dire mais
parce que je le vois souvent avec ma
petite fille en ce moment là on pleure
beaucoup c'est peut-être ça et vous
c'est quoi votre film le dictateur
le dictateur est pas mal en ce moment
c'est parfait le dictateur rien jeter
plus le titre mais un des films de raul
andré que nous avons tourné
ao l'endroit où ça marche à tous les
coups
tu connais toi donc combi qu'il faudrait
les voir ces films là avec toi
il y avait un certain jeu quand même y
avait une liberté incroyable de tout le
monde
l'histoire comme chez moquer un peu nous
en faisait leur film dans la salle lors
d'une étape à tourner dans un film du
metteur en scène disait abandonner
maintenant gaga volonté jeu j'ai fait
des choses semblables mais pas cette
réflexion j'ai pas entendu non non vous
faites ce que vous voulez je m'en fous
ils jouent comme ça
cela dit avec autant lara vous avez
quand même une expérience énorme
invraisemblable deux films et coûteront
la wii et il se comportait de façon
marquante n'est pas content il piétine
et sa casquette et alors ils traiter les
acteurs de petits singes après qu'ils
aient kaka non il vous a dit quelqu'un
moi il m'a si kaka c'est vraiment la
caricature du réalisateur dans les
filles faciles mais classique ils sont
comme des petits seins aussi bien de
mercy voit-on vous restez avec nous on
boit du champagne c'est la 1000e et on
mange un peu j'ai bien sûr tu peux
marcher tout savoir du chanteur r d
hergé spécial millièmes suite avec le
best of des meilleurs moments de télé
passé sur le plateau de la culture
replay amis chers ennemis bonsoir c'est
l'heure de rive droite rive gauche le
seul jt de la culture en compagnie ce
soir de patrick poivre d'arvor
les médicaments contre l'acidité
gastrique et les problèmes hépatiques
que vous voyez sur cette table m'ont été
envoyés par isabelle adjani en souvenir
d'une critique faite sur ce plateau même
par philippe tesson et jacques nerson
c'est le même homme qui la semaine
dernière a osé vente et hamlet mutilé
par encore joué par les médias
et là nous avons de grands acteurs une
version historique de la pièce
et là vous êtes en train de chipoter
c'est ridicule n'est pas m'as fait
dessus tout tient des brames à peine
fait de l'ombre est une anti graisse
l'avait dans le racing semble que ce
soit la voûte c'est la fed ont des
racines sunnites et par là où par la
culpabilité s'est quand même fait la
beauté de la bei mais il faut qu'elle
aime cette honte makosso ces deux
valeurs que sont la forme les champions
fut le schéma là la vitesse on vient de
s'exprimer en alexandrins jamiroquai
vous vous en souvenez
c'était assez fort savoir si vous voyez
des fascistes partout si vous dénoncez
des fascistes partout comment vous allez
mobiliser les gens pour les combattre il
saurait excuser moi pas la télévision
non c'est pas pour ça non excusez moi
donc moi ce que je veux faire c'est
quand même changé le monde
je veux que les gens comprennent que
d'élections à date art
il parle avec ses chevaux avec ses
chariots nini paribas vers l'ouest ils
s'arrêtent devra la ligne
simplifie 7e minute jean les chariots
des chevaux des petits chevaux des types
casqués barre il vivait savoura pirate
bay steve il me donnait pas d'ordre
surtout chaissac tout ce que je vais
dire parce que vous allez me dire je
sais faire et bien vous allez lire
quelques pages non j'ai pas envie je
ferai pas
c'est une projection privée aux femmes
n'est pas vrai et je pensais que c'était
une blague a dérapé les jeter à l'eau
salée si bondy et je vis à peine m une
nouveauté tient il m'a appelé j'étais
alors j'irai voir
je pense que c'était une blague
alors mesdames messieurs nous devions
accueillir maintenant oliver stone et se
trouve que notre bon ami
oliver stone qui n'est plus un bon ami
derrière et complètement stone comme son
nom l'indiqué est que sont édités en
course dans paris parce qu'il est pété
bourré déjanté et il veut absolument
aller se baigner dans une piscine ils
ont toujours pas attraper c'est ma mère
qui vous a raconté ça je sais tout ça ne
c'est pas croyable vous aviez tous
présents mais vous savez ça comment vous
savez ça et voilà j'attendais qu'on me
fait très plaisir vous séparez puisque
ce dernier débat théâtre de l'année et
de la saison de dix ans et que vous
allez vous séparer sur une dispute et
que j'ai un petit peu triste de partir
en vacances non mais dans la cousine se
dit honorée considérez vous la main la
dernière fois voilà non parce que
franchement c'est l'envié de terminer la
saison comme ça merci à tous les deux
[Musique]
voilà donc c'était un best-of des
meilleurs moments des cinq saisons
passées bonsoir jérôme bonsoir tribales
pour 60 ans me sens avec 9o chic pas
chez le cerro avec moi pendant toute
l'émission le parrain c'est normal
l'argent qu'est-ce qu'il ya faisait pas
l'air de bonne humeur là j'ai entendu
beaucoup à c'est pour ça mon avis oui
est-ce que vous avez préparé votre petit
votre petit texte sur la littérature et
la télévision ne rejoue pas par jamais
rien bon vous allez improvisé bon j'en
ai dit nous voilà quelle est la
littérature et la télévision qui sont
vraiment des frères ennemis je dirais
d'une certaine façon puisque maintenant
sur les chaînes hertziennes ya
pratiquement plus d'émissions de
littérature littéraire puisque le
dernier en date c'était guillaume durand
qui devait remplacer bernard pivot mais
s'occupe de l'irak
donc à part patrick poivre d'arvor ya
plus personne et c'est très tardifs sont
négligemment il faudrait faire une
émission de littérature avec 9
peut-être et vous ouais et il faudrait
la mettre à 8h30 alors là on viendrait à
20 heures 20 heures à la place du
journal mais c'est vrai sur paris il y
avait celle fils qui fait une bonne
émission et sur les chaînes hertziennes
ya plus rien ce que devraient faire les
écrivains au fond peut-être est ce
qu'ils font quelquefois c'est de ne pas
venir à la télévision
vous trahissez ans seulement
naturellement ils viennent pourquoi ils
viennent parce qu'ils ont envie de
vendre leurs livres
je n'ai jamais volé télévision 1 vous
déjà mais vous la télévision mais
comment naturellement
un livre mais au fond la sagesse c'est
c'est marcel aymé ne sais pas qui ne
disait jamais rien qui ne parlait jamais
un livre il ya une histoire de marcel
aymé que j'aime beaucoup c'est il
voulait jamais parlé même de ses propres
livres et a joué dans un dîner y est à
côté d'une dame comme ça qui fait un peu
de gêne et qui lui dit monsieur marcel
aymé j'ai je me suis juré de vous
arracher plus le 3 parole ouais et
marcel aymé lui répond vous avez perdu
est-ce qu'on croyait jean sérieusement
inquiéter crespin est ce que vous croyez
que vous auriez vendu autant de livres
si vous n'étiez pas venu aussi souvent à
la télévision
mais pourquoi croyez vous que je suis
venu ici ce soir c'est pour vous
remercier de m'avoir aidé avant de tout
laisser pour en vendre 5 sens bien ça
s'est bien vendu donc ça va est ce qu'on
peut dire c'est ty yann est ce que les
ventes s'étaient bien écoutez ça va il
ya des petites choses à l'extérieur qui
nuisent un peu au livre en ce moment
comme vous avez mais enfin quand même
gens pour vous c'est très facile parce
qu'on sait très bien que les gens aiment
ce que vous écrivez
mais on aime aussi l'homme alors l'homme
qui vient se montrer à la télévision
avec cette espèce d'allégresse ironique
et cette espèce de stupeur face au monde
c'était incroyablement attrayant et bien
savez c'est une wii c'est tout le
problème de lecture baceco l'écrivain on
le juge sur ce qu'il fait à la radio et
plus encore
ce qui fait à la télévision et il est
tout à fait évident que le livre peut
être bon et l'écrivain exécrable la
télévision ou que le livre peut être
exécrable et et l'écrivain à la
télévision mais elle est sacrée une
espèce de troubles chez l'écrivain
nous allons rejeter rit parce que l'on
peut faire il ya quand même un type
d'écrivain c'est à dire modiano ou
houellebecq qui sont excellent écrivain
très mauvais à la télé mais justement
ils sont tellement mauvais que les gens
s'y intéressent dire que mondiale gens
attendent de voir comment il va pas y
arriver à parler de son livre quoi alors
vous me disiez tout à l'heure que la
vallée à de mauvaise humeur c'était
peut-être je me disais il faut essayer
de faire comme sa tâche et des petits
mauvais à la télévision c'est raté ce
soir communisme c'était tellement drôle
c'est que même dans les supermarchés
maintenant comme com enfin pour attirer
le chaland
alors il ya des produits tout à fait
divers et c'est écrit en rouge veut à la
télé oui et alors voila si ses vues à la
télé ça sent mais je ne voudrais pas
raviver des souvenirs douloureux mais
jean a animé une émission littéraire qui
s'appelait comment déjà livres ont fait
voilà l'ifab a quand même j'avais
j'avais découvert un livre qui était pas
si mal je compte que j'avais été le
premier en parler j'étais l'ami retrouvé
c'est vrai tu te rappelles ça l'ami
retrouvé jean d'ormesson aurait aussi
lancé le fusil de chasse il chargea
pauline ou est épatant alors en réalité
votre jour off
ma journée off et il faut dire que ce
rendez vous de l'opéra comique comme ça
chaque soir est tout de même une
expérience exaltante au plus haut point
c'est la féerie l'enchantement la tâche
bien non oui oui ça ça c'est pas moi j'y
suis allée toute ma famille et adorait
tournée alors on va passer assez petit
questionnaire formaté donc le lit pas
complètement de votre livre préféré vous
dit
histoire de frank derycke 9 évidemment
il avoue même mauvais quand ils parlent
délicate élection c'est à mal son leader
[Musique]
est un très bon livre d'abord j'aime
tout ce que fait nov
je trouve que c'est très très bien
toujours et là je me suis dit ça c'est
pas pour moi l'europe et c'était pas
tant on voit sinatra qui baissent tout
le temps qu'ils boivent tout le temps
c'est assez fréquent déjà la mafia dia
les yeux bleus il a les yeux bleus
l'histoire de frank de 9 le film sur la
route de madison ça je comprends qu'ils
disent tout bon d'accord pas besoin de
faire de dessin théâtre j'ai pleuré
beaucoup grand romantique gens et
théâtre alors fait de patrice chéreau
dont fait partie des gens parce que nous
ici on est des grands débats entre tes
son aîné ressent pour savoir si si le
phèdre de cheyrou était acceptable
vous êtes pour je suis surtout pour
faire ouais voilà c'est fait qu'elle
soit jouée par la parle hauts-de-seine
par là par l'onu je trouve que ce
n'était pas tant de voir qu elle renaît
sans cesse ses cendres voilà c'est quand
même très beau et en chansons j'avais
choisi vincent delerm et c'est vrai que
c'est très très bien parce que c'est pas
vincent delerm j'ai découvert aux
victoires de la musique
et c'est vrai qu'il est une chanson qui
s'appelle t par an je crois si vous les
connaissez qui est vraiment formidable
les parents ils doivent lire télérama et
tous extraordinaires
il ya évidemment deux chansons qui m'a
frappé ces derniers temps c'est carla
bruni way qui est aussi belle que ma
voisine c'est pas peu dire
et de l'air mais évidemment mittler son
père a bien écrit sous les 6
c'est l'office de la première gorgée
c'est le 1 million d'exemplaires
oui mais c'était irrésistible pas
combien un million d'exemplaires en
france éditions originales à la
résistivité comme si on retrouve les
passes et ex qui ce soir et j'ai pas
d'accent télé alors ariel je vais
préparer un petit compliment sur la sur
la musique maintenant à son de la
musique non je voulais simplement
signifié non grand enthousiasme
j'ai fait partie pour la première fois
des restos du coeur cette année et j'ai
découvert jean jacques goldman alors ça
semble peut-être comme ça évident et je
me suis aperçu qu'en réalité c'était un
héros national et que je le connaissais
un peu comme comme molière qui découvre
qu'il qu'il fait de la prose sans le
savoir eh bien nous connaissons tous
très bien
jean jacques goldman parce qu'il écrit
il écrit pour tout le monde et c'est dur
même pensé l'union mais alors justement
jeu ce qui est important aussi par
rapport à céline dion c'est que goldman
a pour 1 sortie du ghetto les chanteuses
à voix c'est le premier qui qui a écrit
des chansons intelligente pour des gens
qui avaient des belles voix et il s'est
dit pourquoi est ce que quand on pense
belle voix c'est toujours mireille
mathieu ou michèle torr et aimer mais
quand c'est l'amérique c'est whitney
houston bon et il a écrit pour céline
dion et il l'a mis sur une orbite si
vous voulez spéciale de chansons et
loriol chanter du goldman oui j'aimerais
beaucoup que j'ai adoré son dernier
album et puis je me rends compte que
j'ai par exemple
rappelez vous de la chanson de khaled
qui l'a écrit aïcha très belle chanson
oui ça c'était la commande doit jouer à
aïcha
reste un fake -1 à nana na na na na ça
c'est super bon tout lâche la france et
tout à coup devenu s'est mis dans le
rythme de l'islam le plus langoureux
c'était génial bon eh bien oui eh bien
tu sais pas quand qu'encore qu'ariel a
dit j'ai découvert cg je ne savais pas
que c'était un rôle national j'ai cru
que c'était un pseudonyme de zidane
parce que vous voyez il ya les rôles
nationaux son lap l'abbé pierre je ne
sais pas si vous en êtes avant tout cas
l'abbé pierre en est un
et puis y'a douillet et je suis d'accord
dans lequel ils vivent
j'ai tout trésor vivant déjà réussi ce
soir 0 et d'ormesson alors ariel votre
livre préféré c théâtre intime de jérôme
garcin
oui parce que je lis en ce moment ça
vous plaît c'est vrai bébé quand quand
vous posez la question il faut remonter
à 5 ans en arrière alors évidemment
beigbeder houellebecq neuhof bernard
henri salesse à berlin quand même mais
en quatrième position on remarque non
non je ne nie pas et les vous savez bien
lui l'entraîneur m'a enlevé tout en
train de finir au lit blanc est vrai que
je suis très très bouleversée par ce
livre qui me touche parce que c'est cet
amour inconditionnel de cette femme
qu'est sa femme et qui lui échappe
toujours puisqu'elle est une actrice
c'est qu'elle est donc ça c'est le livre
le film signe de mood for love de wong
kar-wai du monde est d'accord au théâtre
frédéric au boulevard du crime de eric
emmanuel schmitt
oui mais surtout parce que j'adore jean
paul belmondo et quand je les ai vus
dans cette pièce bien
il marque mais oui tout de même parce
que du coup c'est classique
oui ensuite la chanson chambre 1052
green kamel morjane ce que ingrid c'est
une figure même comme il y en a presque
plus c'est à dire c'est un mélange de
marley
mais 2 et des bas fonds de berlin c'est
quelqu'un de tout à fait singulier donc
j'adore ingrid caven mouais alors avant
de se séparer ariel bernard henri lévy
est en train de terminer un livre il est
au maximum la cei doit il doit rendre le
manuscrit là ces jours-ci donc il doit
être dans tous ses états non vous savez
je crois que quand on a fait l'école
normale supérieure on vous apprend
vraiment à bosser et alors c'est vrai
que quand on le voit comme ça les les
dernières heures sur le malus mais
j'imagine que c'est souvent comme ça
pour les écrivains bien il ya un état
tout à une espèce d'effervescence
terrifiante qui est là et c'est la
machine à penser c'est pas un peu
difficile dans ces moments-là de vivre
avec lui n'ont alors moi j'adore ah bon
s'il devait pas insupportable rien n'est
plus rassurant les gens dans la vie
s'ennuie sont médisants attendent la
mort voilà l'ale l'autoroute qui mène au
cimetière
en général les gens là et alors quand tu
en as merci à tous d'avoir été avec nous
michel on va on va passer la pub et au
retour de pub je m'en viens de faire un
petit bilan déjà de la situation jusqu'à
maintenant fait un petit bilan je crois
que c'est important de faire un peu de
la situation
merci jean merci merci à eric n'a fait
que de la figuration intelligente et qui
les a tous les jours après les pubs
placer la suite de se r d hergé spécial
millièmes toujours en compagnie de
michel serrault plus andré dussollier
mélanie doutey axelle laffont et jean
pierre mocky a plus
[Musique]
chers amis chers ennemis re bonsoir je
vous rappelle qu'à l'occasion de cette
spéciale millièmes
il y à 1000 places de cinéma à gagner
wimille place il suffit de cliquer sur
paris tiré premiere.fr et maintenant
donc nous passons à la suite de cette
spéciale millièmes bonsoir peggy olmi
bonsoir andré dussollier rebond soit
remis à michel serrault vous êtes
invités d'honneur prévu que j'ai changé
de place ouais c'est pas mal parce que
ce que vous pouvez faire surtout c'est
intervenir quand vous voulez parce que
c'est un petit peu votre émission j'ai
peur que ça à faire mon pote
ouais vous êtes le parrain du truc quand
même quoi et alain riou comment ça va
aller très bien alors pki donc cette
émission existe depuis six ans et ça
fait six ans que vous avez commencé à
travailler dans la culture and we
d'abord en presse et l'ironie du sort
fait que rive droite rive gauche était
mon émission préférée du monde au monde
y est maintenant dans les voiles à
écouter vous êtes contente ça s'est bien
passé s'est félicité jean fleury
contente vous êtes assez gentil royal
sera encore là la 2000e j'ai pas très à
mon avis oui avec plaisir
alors andré ya le film qui sort la
l'effroyable jardin moi j'ai pas vu le
film encore j'ai vu la bande annonce
ça a l'air extraordinaires non c'est
bien c'est encore un film de jean becker
on avait tourné d'ailleurs avec michel
les enfants du marais
d'inr les enfants tu arrivé c'est un
beau soir aux quatre depuis jamais la
drôme effectivement kevin rudd
et non là c'est s est adapté du film du
livre de michel quint écrire le jardin
est bon c'est une histoire qui se passe
pendant la guerre ou de type vont
essayer de se lancer dans une aventure
qui les dépasse
faire un acte de résistance pour l'amour
d'une femme et il ya toujours ce mélange
avec film de jean becker entre la
légèreté le comique et pilar l'émotion
lang cô tes petits deals de ce sens oui
c'est ça comment on peut faire un film
tu pas d'une heure et demie à partir
d'un livre de 60 pages là il faut il
faut être fidèle à l'esprit est un
fidèle à la lettre quoi il faut essayer
de refaire pour l'image ce qu'on a aimé
dans le livre mais il là ils ont été
justement ils sont ils sont accordés pas
mal de liberté et je trouve que c'est
pas moi de le dire mais enfin le
résultat est bien là c'est ce qu'on a vu
salaire soit très bien oui oui ces
roquets ce que vous faites de quoi vous
parlez là tous les deux à zéro d'ici là
livre n'est jamais qu'un point de départ
ouais non pour un film en tout cas oui
c'est un point de départ et vous savez
ce qu'il va faire andré après à partir
du 14 mai au rond-point nom et pas après
les monologues du vagin il y a les
monologues du sportif
juppé rocard a pas rêvé au matin mais
enfin
tant pis s'il est non enfin lewis est
passé de cesser des textes de paul
fournel en fait ce sont des monologues
de sportifs en effet mais qu'il a écrit
lui-même un c'est pas des interviews et
je vais jouer le footballeur le cycliste
voilà je me donnais mais j'aime beaucoup
le sport alors fait ça et le théâtre
aussi donc à l'occasion faire les deux
en même temps c'est pas mal non cédées
portrait assez savoureux de ce portail
excite à l'auteur vivons oui oui c'est
avec city avec toujours des auteurs
fournel c'est un auteur vivant
effectivement fait plus de théâtre vous
là non ça n'a juste rien certes non
la france finit deuxième question je
voudrais poser à ces messieurs parce
qu'il ya une geisha de très intéressant
qui oppose michel serrault et andré
dussolier c'est que ce héros a réussi en
acceptant tous et que du soulier a
réussi en acceptant rien mais ce héros à
vous avez à peu près à accepter tout ce
qu'on vous a proposé à vos débuts au
civil parce que je suis une grande
prétention je dis ça n'est pas pourquoi
on peut s'arranger et du soulier au
contraire vous avez été l'homme du de
l'exigence du refuge est d'ailleurs
impressionnant de lire votre
filmographie
c'étaient les choses se font un peu par
hasard hein c'est pas on n'a pas autant
de
de pouvoirs de décision que ce à quoi
d'abord on nous propose à un michel et
purent ensuite mes envies mais oui on
est bien
je pars avec un taux qui m'amuse
beaucoup quand je lui quelque chose dit
qu'est ce que je vous donnerai est ce
que ça vaut le coup de se met en route
pour ça parce que c'est quand même que
une proposition c'est sur le papier les
comédiens on ne connaît pas tous le
metteur en scène pas toujours du terrain
donc c'est une aventure
alors si vous avez eu ce n'est pas la
pièce en six actes d' isoler le premier
pas mal et puis le quatrième
we say die on verra bien parce que
finalement ça que ça se fait quand même
un peu sur le terrain quand même et puis
c'est la rencontre avec les comédiens
etc
mais je crois que et je dirais même
chose je veux pas dire trop fort - c'est
bon plus ça m'excite
il ya peut-être une manière de faire
passer ça aura mauvais scénario d'août
mais au théâtre c'est pareil aussi de
temps en temps il ya des secteurs pas
terrible et un jour tu dis si on joue ça
comme ça ça doit aller on peut coiffer
sa mission c'est l'intuition qui entre
nous c'est que derrière les mots
derrière la la la la proposition
derrière la situation qu'on vous donne
allait pas à l'est pas c'est pas fini il
faut des acteurs laptop qui vont
inventer
pourquoi pas alors si comme tout s'est
jamais à 100%
moi j'ai jamais fait un privilège de
faire un choix j'ai quand même un pari
incroyable canon bien sûr sépare donc je
crois qu'il faut se lancer et sa force
jeudi mythe comme dans on peut jouer
nous devons sortir mes cadets s'est
demandé à du soulier de faire un
truffaut directement alors que vous
étiez à l'académie française n'avait pas
beaucoup d'expérience ça doit faire
quand même de les fêtes ça fait de
l'effet surtout ce oui c'est un pas que
je pouvais tourner le dos à la caméra
j'ai été vraiment comment dire c'est un
apprenti comédien de théâtre donc je
découvrais le cinéma en même temps mais
oui c'est le plaisir yahia souvent je
reviens sur ce que dit michel parce que
on dit souvent dans notre métier pour
élire le bottin oui c'est vrai que lire
le bottin on pourrait trouver du plaisir
à lire le mot juste c'est pas juste une
vanne oui et alors faudrait pour ça
sereine avec des comédiens du ferro
salut potins différents autant à marc
andré votre film préféré
mon film préféré tous les films que vous
avez dans votre vie que j'ai vu dans la
vie de 5 ans 10 ans le premier que j'ai
vu allez tiens je vais dire depuis cinq
ans et wise wide shut coin de quick
vous avez aimé ça moi j'ai bien aimé
c'est beaucoup aimé mais sinon je vais
dire un des premiers que j'ai vu alors
comme ça pour remonter dans le temps
puisque c'est quand passent les cigognes
soviétique ça m'avait beaucoup marqué
c'est un mélo mais voilà j'avais ça
m'avait touché j'avais rencontré cinéma
à travers ce fil est le livre qui vous a
marqué depuis cinq ans le prochain
kundera par ses classes au théâtre ce
qui vous a marqué depuis cinq ans à une
tête sur la lune j'ai beaucoup aimé
cette pièce là qui avait été monté par
irina brook et bien ça parce que c'est
rare d'avoir des pièces contemporaines
et donc là vraiment il y avait tout d'un
coup un sujet et
un spectacle magnifique alors maintenant
vous allez faire un cadeau à péguy à moi
je voudrais vous lui disiez auquel je
pense à peggy parce que dans ce réseau
de câbles très coquin c'est a justement
ça m'intéresse c'est peut-être moins
intimidés et non je vais m'adresser à la
caméra on va penser que je la drague et
pouvant évidemment c'est un poème de la
b2 l'atteignant c'est un chanoine du
xviiie bon alors je regarde qui elle est
où la votre ami imaginaire mannala quel
est votre mot et sur le mot et sur la
chose on vous a dit souvent le mot vous
a fait souvent la chose ainsi de la
chose et d'humour vous pouvez dire
quelque chose je gagerais que le mot
vous plaît beaucoup moins que la chose
pour moi voici quel est mon beau et sur
le mot et sur la sho j'avouerai que
j'aime le j'aimerais que j'aime la chose
mais c'est la chose avec le mot mais
c'est le mot avec la chose autrement la
chose et le mot à mes yeux serait peu de
choses je crois même en faveur du mot
pouvoir ajouter quelque chose d'une
chose qui donne au mot tout l' avantage
sur la chose c'est qu'on peut dire
encore le mot alors qu'on ne fait plus
la chose et pour peu que vaille le mot
mon dieu c'est toujours quelque chose de
là je conclus que le mot doit être remis
avant la chose qu'il ne faut ajouter au
moc autant que l'on peut quelque chose
et que pour le jour le mot viendra seul
hélas en la chose il faut se réserver le
mot pour se consoler de la chose pour
vous je crois qu'avec le mot vous voyez
toujours autre chose vous dites si
gaiement le mot vous méritez si bien la
chose que pour vous la chose et le mot
devrait être la même chose et vous
n'avez pas dit le mot qu'on est déjà
prêt à la chose mais quand je dis que le
mot tout est remis avant la chose vous
devez me croire à ce mot bien que le
connaisseur à la chose et bien voici mon
dernier mot et sur le mot et sur la
chose madame pas c'est moi le mot et je
vous passerai la chose c'est génial
bravo
saab est un coquin tu écris une chanson
très connue quand les enfants
innocemment sais j'ai du bon tabac dans
ma tabatière mais ce n'est pas ça le
texte et s'adresser là aussi aux dames
j'ai du bon tabac dedans mais tabatière
voilà d'accord que vous avez tout bon
bravo au pays et houdrouge merci en tous
les cas l'un merci andré bercy teddy
suite de cette édition millièmes avec le
meilleur et le pire de ma première
émission
c'était le lundi 6 octobre 1997
ripley chers amis chers ennemis bonsoir
voici rive droite rive gauche
tous les soirs à 19h nous nous
retrouverons ici pour un apéritif pas
comme les autres puisqu'il s'agit d'un
cocktail culturel culturel parce qu'on
parlera de livres de films de disques
d'expos de médias et plus rarement de
sexe et voilà donc c'était en 1997 le 6
octobre c'était le premier à l'époque
rive droite rive gauche qui devenu
depuis rdr j'ai re bonsoir philippon
soir axelle laffont bonsoir mélanie
doutey bonsoir jacques nerson michel
serrault le parrain de l'émission et de
cette soirée en particulier donc vous
d'habitude assez lundi c'est génial
d'habitude vous êtes donc sur scène
voilà au palais royal dans l'éventail de
lady windermere parce que si je lui dis
20 dernière est tellement gueule d'oscar
wilde et c'est jusqu'au 31 mai c'est ça
ou puisse on ne sait pas ou plus si
affinités et vous access et onenote
chaud donc au palais des glaces depuis
le 14 janvier et prolongé jusqu'à fin
juin dont 1
on n'a que des gens qui font des
prolongations je suis un garçon que vous
êtes très fan de mélanie doutey vous
chez moi c'est un seul endroit
alors vous cette douce et vous aussi
vous c'est carré lui ne vous disputez
mais ils sont bien tous les deux ils ont
chacun leur charme
bougherra dispute tout le temps sa fin
naturelle et il est en train de dire
qu'il est il a dit du bien de ce
spectacle c'est pas vrai et en jeune et
je n'ai pas dix ans vous avez
présentable c'est fini et je sais qu'on
a compris
arbitre vous êtes le fan absolu de
mélanie doutey alors que c'est plutôt
isabelle carré excusez moi d'habitude
est là parce qu'elle est là ce soir
franchement je peux avoir deux étoiles
dans mon ciel quoi sur les ailes mais je
n'ai pas été fan de l'éventail de lady
windermere mais je suis fan de mélanie
doutey avec away à cause du chabrol mais
que vous ne l'avez vous dit avant je
l'avais dit n'en veut pas dire 2006 et
leur cinéma
c'est vrai qu'elle est elle est très
belle elle est vraiment le moment de
grâce de ce spectacle comme dans le
premier rôle c'est un long moment titre
n'a pas le premier rôle c'est solide
ailier qu'elle provient c'est vrai enfin
à mon avis philippe a dormi pendant le
temps de la représentation
comment ils sont ah oui ce wagon pour
eux c'était et puis des fois quand ils
font des débats je te garantis que ça
continue après l'émission ils
s'engueulent dans les loges des
maquillages c'est absolument
extraordinaire c'est oscar wilde que je
m'en étais pris parce que c'est très
brillant c'était une cascade de formules
extrêmement brillante mais on oublie les
choses aux idéaux qu'on les a entendus
tout agréable
oui oui je ne cherche pas au palais avec
caroline cellier
mélanie doutey jocelyn quivrin voilà
voilà
yves gasc et yves gaspal très beau
spectacle que je vous enjoins bien
entendu moi je vais tous les soirs pour
vous voir moi je l'attends devant là je
pleure devant la sortie des artistes ont
déjà fait ce qu'elles sortent les jardy
sonia iront les hardis sonia doigts
tendus traduisant ses biens sont fans
des bruits alors dites moi alors
attention mais à écouter le petit livre
préféré donc c'est le monde selon garp
non c'est pas mon livre préféré mais on
m'a demandé de choisir un livre que j'ai
quitté ses sorties après 97 ans j'ai dit
le monde selon garp parce qu'il est lié
au conservatoire pour moi parce que j'ai
travaillé sur ce texte au conservatoire
mais c'est pas mon livre préféré mais
trop comment il préférait c'est enfin de
ce que j'ai lu c'est plus
la biographie de marie antoinette de
stefan zweig qui m'a beaucoup ému et les
biographies de ce bug son sublime bien
c'est une très bonne réponse à mal le
film sait comment tuer son comment tuer
le chien de son voisin dernier film que
j'ai vu c'est un bijou
ah bon avec amical que les semis co
alors c'est quoi l'histoire le pitch
prend là je pourrai pas voulu faire
comme ça ça parle de quoi
c'est l'histoire d'un couple ouais une
semaine bien et évidemment au théâtre
l'éventail de lady windermere
ben oui mais non mais le spectacle
d'axelle laffont one love chose
peut-être l'autocélébration ça se
pratique beaucoup dans cette pratique
beaucoup de vent debout vote libre
évidemment l'immortalité de midane
kundera est toujours bien ça s'ériger en
fait je suis au milieu là et je lis un
peu tout ce qui se rapporte à la mort ce
que j'ai un peu une grande angoisse et
de la mort puisque j'en parle dans mon
spectacle
comme vous le savez bien de sortir et
donc j'essaye de rade de lire des choses
qui me rassure sur le fait que c'est
bien d'être mortel mentalité kundera le
film the hours belge vient de voir chez
c'est un film sublime
c'est un film de femmes magnifiques
elles sont toutes incroyable dedans de
nicole kidman avec son faux nez oui
toutes deux dans son incroyable mais
maitient au théâtre évidemment one man
show non moi je dis au théâtre j'ai pas
parlé de moi car avant d'accord c'est de
l'auto célébration dans l'éventail de
lady
non je parlais de cèpes d'accord et
norah jones comme album c'est bien
visible 1 c'est bien aussi
et l'événement vous préférez c'est la
millième de rdr c'est génial on vient de
danser c'est la fête
on a un peu saoul moi je voulais dire
que j'avais fait de mon premier premier
truc que j'ai fait c'est la figuration
dans un film avec michel serrault
c'était la cage aux folles 2es jeux cage
aux folles vous souvenez pas ça mais si
vous mangez de biscottes
j'étais en italie parce que c'est mon
beau père qui a réalisé ce film voilà
mauritius votre micro devant votre
bouche que tu dis non c'est pardon
regard barjon micro personnel vous vous
ne me souvenais pas d'axelle laffont
signature entre médias vous êtes resté
longtemps là-bas non j'ai sucé des
glaces devant la presse la caméra et
vous passiez devant moi vous étiez
magnifique c'est pas suffisant mais ça
l'a lancée depuis oui oui elle provient
lorsque vous jouez au théâtre parce que
j'entends je fais un spectacle
un one woman show qu'est ce qu'il a
manqué ce qu'il a c'est vrai que ça se
passe au palais des glaces du mardi au
samedi
[Musique]
j'espère je viendrai avec adams héros
bon bah merci un merci axel à bientôt
vous rester dans les parages vous non
quand même stéphane bon alors suite de
cette spéciale millièmes avec le best-of
des premières chroniques ah bah oui je
comprends pourquoi ils restent les
premières chroniques de philippe tesson
madame qu'un flot avec beigbeder patrice
carmouze bipper escarmouches bonsoir
bonsoir donc tous les soirs vous
viendrez nous faire un petit billet sur
l'air du temps culturel et ce soir on
vous a demandé de réfléchir sur
l'attaqué en règle dont sont victimes
les intellectuels français
oui et j'ai bien réfléchi je suis sûr
c'est bien ça se voit non mais ça va pas
je veux absolument
alors j'ai réfléchi et je me suis dit
qu'on pourrait rapprocher cette affaire
en effet de l'attak dont sont victimes
les intellectuels français dont on dit
que quand il parle de science ils disent
à peu n'importe quoi les intellectuels
voyez ce que je fais là je pense et je
crois que c'est ça qui est un
intellectuel intellectuelle sa panse
pour vous l'intellectuel d'ailleurs
avant de faire ça pense qu'ils pensent
d'ailleurs il le dit souvent il dit je
pense donc je suis et c'est vrai un
intellectuel qui ne penseraient pas ben
ne serez pas grand chose
avant de parler du film aux allures un
mot au sujet de kim bassinger bah oui
pourquoi 50 galère galère parce que vous
savez il avait refusé le film psycho
sadique que jennifer lynn je voulais lui
faire faire boxing helena elle a dû
payer un dédié assez conséquent ensuite
elle a une mégalomanie foncière
bizarroïdes elle a acheté un village en
géorgie ça s'est cassé la gueule
rod est qu'elle enchaînait flop sur flop
sur flop vous souvenez pas d'apporter il
ya eu trois films bouton souviens pas
faut-il aimer des côtelettes
pour en débattre avec nous philippe
tesson à ma droite vous c'est terrible
pas dans le figaro magazine on vous êtes
chroniqueur dramatique voulu assassiner
cette pièce nul voilà donc c'était les
débuts de nos amis chroniqueur vie à
lisabeth doute y est formidable dans ce
danser
vraiment en prenait le micro de ce héros
vous êtes nuls avec vos cheveux longs
qui à l'époque excusez moi vous n'aviez
pas tous ses bijoux et ses robes hors de
prix et j'avais des loges elle vous
aviez +25 maintenant oui c'est vrai
parlant des sauveteurs suisses et au fil
des années que j'ai couvert hijab est de
bijoux ah non mais maintenant elle fait
beaucoup plus fiche maintenant c'est
vraiment un bon ça n'est pas charitable
tout de même devoir montrer que mes
pages ou un ouais mais là on a vu on a
vu dans que les débuts de carmes où j'ai
débuté dès les débuts de tout le monde
payer pour le dise un truc aimable mais
je ne suis pas ce que vous croyez ils me
payent pour que je dise un truc aimable
mesdames et messieurs c'est la
correction car l'eau dessalée dit un
truc là-bas elisabeth titube bien du
bien de son prochain film
à moins que cinq sens je parle pas bon
bien on continue à leur attention
vous restez avec nous je sais pas si oui
ou non il dit non mais t'as pour une
fois qu'ils avaient des grossesses
vraiment stéphane tes chiens comme
vraiment je te jure meliani vous parti
tout de suite
alors peut-être pas tout de suite mais
je vais laisser la place d'accords et
vous accepte car quand vous voyez non je
vais rester juste derrière tu restes un
peu mais ok suite de cette spéciale
millièmes avec le meilleur des pires
coups de gueule pour ces par le gang de
la culture replay c'est couillon mon nom
c'est chiant c'est branché c'est inès
est taillée dans une langue de bois dont
on pourrait faire des queues de billard
là on reste effectivement au niveau du
caca pipi fait totalement inepte c'est
raciste et fasciste c'est plutôt là
dessus je savais bien que j'avais raison
by aleph basterds le film de sophie
marceau je ne m'étendrai pas dessus par
charité je crains que ce soit absolument
de la bouillie pour les chats on va nous
dire vous êtes des vrais thèmes vous
attacher au détail l'aide est vrai petit
merdeux
le film est tellement vide et inepte et
ridicule et grandiloquent et pompeux
qu'on ne voit plus que le détail obsède
c'est complètement con ça se passe à
hollywood le tournage d'un tournage d'un
tournage et c'est le comble de
l'arrogance du cinéaste de la côte ouest
qui parce qu'il fait quelques succès se
permet de nous polluer que ça donc c'est
nul c'est bien énervé dans ce spectacle
est tellement insignifiant avant que
finalement ce pas chine mérite pas que
nous passions à autre chose je ne sais
pas quel est l'âge exact d'isabelle
adjani ça m'est égal
mais elle n'a de toute évidence pas
l'âge du personnage non plus et pam a
fait c'est tout et comme je vous vois en
plus disposer d'un vocabulaire limité et
nous sortir toujours les mêmes gags
toujours les mêmes images aujourd'hui au
bout d'un moment j'avoue je dis il y en
a assez maintenant je n'ai pas besoin de
voir le gros visage d'isabelle huppert
merveilleuse ailleurs gros jubal legros
visage de ses parts au visage par la
remplir et fanny ardant tout bois j'ai
envie d'être épaté de m'amuser de
trouver quelque chose qui ressemble à
cette jeune femme qui est douce qui est
pétillante qui espiègle sympa et tout ça
et puis je trouve mais vraiment quelque
chose qui est très très très surprenant
apr un peu un peu déjà vu souvent un peu
banal voire bêta quoi le support elle
merci pour la littérature
christine angot et sa propre passion
c'est le georges marchais de la
littérature est là le côté la
littérature c'est moi tous les autres
c'est nul et taisez vous et c'est
affligeant merci pour l merci pour la
littérature je sais pas si olivier
besancenot l'a écrit lui-même mon avis
le facteur devrait toujours signé deux
fois celle de son nom et celui de son
[ __ ]
c'est très très très mauvais merci pour
lui l'entente compte jamiroquai là
le nouvel album de johnny à la vie à la
mort ça serait plutôt à la mort fort moi
je cite si j'avais le sida avoir étude
au monde vers ferais-tu l'amour avec moi
à l'endroit à l'envers
la réponse est non francis merci pour
lui c'est fini pour aujourd'hui
voilà donc c'était des coups tu vivre de
r d hergé avec nous sur ce plateau donc
arnaud viviant bonsoir soit au nom vous
êtes dans l'émission depuis combien de
temps ça fait quand même quatre cinq ans
4 5 ans déjà
jean pierre mocky bonsoir michel
serrault par hazem kashouh ouais bah oui
vous êtes là depuis 6 ans maintenu toi
déjà souvent pas toujours beau mon book
bien sûr bien sûr les bébés bientôt
micro devant ta bouche quand tu parles
d'un jt méchanceté comme m teresa
quant à lui à la voile a vraiment une
découverte de 2 rue droite rive gauche
cette année j'arrive dans un petit peu
avant mais cette année je pense est
vraiment imposé françois simon et vous
je crois que vous êtes les deux vraiment
trouvaille de l'année dans tous les cas
mon sens et vous êtes bien méchant bien
énervé un aigri bien dégueulasse bien
aigri bien pourri hays frappe il est
c'est une teigne ce mec c'est une teigne
c'est pour ça qu'on aime à la mi la
banque a en font un romantisme et c'est
vraiment une [ __ ] quand je dirais
alors me kyi dont vous faites un film
qui s'appelle tueur s'engage
oui avec ce héros vivrait robin renucci
dick rivers karl zéro rail ma bien aimée
et la main tendue
voilà est sortie prévue en septembre
voilà vous en êtes où la du film un j'en
ai j'en suis au mixage un peu moins bien
cosma avec sa musique ah ouais c'est
quoi le pitch en gros quoi l'histoire
comme ça bah c'est l'histoire d'un
serrurier assassin qui est conseillé par
un méchant qui est monsieur serrault et
y allons seuls aussi demandé aujourd'hui
mon brave au film toute façon alors on
vous a demandé que qu'elle était donc
votre livre votre film x terra préféré
alors le livre sache je comprends très
bien je suis d'accord avec vous ses
amours noir de dominique noguez oui
c'est un étonnant
oui c'est un copain en plus oui je vais
dire du bien je dois dire effectivement
dans les caisses j'aime faire un livre
sur welbeck conseil michel houellebecq
qui s'appelle houellebecq en fait et qui
était un premier livre écrit sur welbeck
en tant qu'écrivain donc le film le
pianiste de roman polanski ne pourrait
pas trop de risque énorme et c'est parce
que j'ai aussi un ami et ses amis
acteurs c'est zéro c'est un truc pour
nos amis téléspectateurs sa fille voit
bien ce soir tout le monde donc au
théâtre limiers d'entonner chéri mais
pas à cause de l'interprétation à cause
de la pièce pourquoi
l'interprétation avant voulais pas je
les ai vus avec laurence olivier michael
caine du film de mankiewicz bien sûr
monsieur terme au théâtre j'ai trouvé ça
plutôt pas mal ou bien oui alors chanson
alors l'attention
votre chanson préférée ses soli sims to
be de rares de sword de elton john en
duo avec blouf ah oui oui ça ça vous
plaît mais ça c'est aussi parce qu'ils
sont m'avait dit un jour que le carton
jaune
maintenant je les aime bien ouais c'est
un copain aussi mais c'est tous des
copains
vous connaissez depuis combien de temps
tous les deux là ça fait très longtemps
très longtemps 66 ap
allez moi mathilde j'ai croisé dans un
couloir ouais il m'a dit j'aimerais bien
travailler avec vous et puis on est
restés fidèles après on s'est un peu
éloigné puis ancien remis ensemble quoi
vous avez fait combien de films bon sens
l'attaqué donc dizaine un peu me disais
c'est ça le miraculé à la miraculée
c'est génial film edit chef-d'oeuvre
ouais mais c'est vrai que par exemple ça
film extraordinaire non mais vous savez
il ya plus d'acteurs alors il y en a un
là il ya quelques autres oui ils sont
vraiment rares pourquoi vous aimez
bosser avec lui lui
ouais mais parce qu'il est très exigeant
il n'a beaucoup d'argent à bord est une
pizza
alors vécu m'a dit que j'avais sans
pizzeria mais je n'ai même pas une
petite
parce que et alors ça il ya des
confusions extraordinaire on dit que
j'aime pas les autres quelqu'un me
disait quand on vous parle de cinéma
vous parlez jamais de sauter vous
connaissez je ne crie commises en
êtes-vous avec votre cinéma là bas il
est mourant il meurt doucement mais on
joue plus que trois jours pourquoi vous
refaites pas un cinéma porno non ça
marcherait pas pourrons-nous non non non
les le port nommés puis ça fait bon des
personnes maintenant je vous dis bien
des questions posées à meaux qui est un
des derniers 1 le dernier des mohicans
quand même c'est moi j'ai lu qu'il avait
127 enfants illégitimes ou je sais plus
combien ça c'est une histoire d'hommes
et c est ce que c'est vrai ça non mais
sérieux est-ce qu'on c'est vrai enfin
jamais illégitime combien j'en sais rien
mon vieux passes en 27 ans à mon avis a
touché juste parce que ça les emmerde
que tu restes de cire d'abeille en
attend en tout cas voilà c'est bien ben
c'est sa rose rose et oui mais je vais
la rose et tout à l'heure avec la wii
mais c'est bien lui donc félicitations
merci mais vous savez plusieurs mois
j'en ai déjà fait trois scientifiques
qui fait plus d'enfants que deux films
est forcément un bon gars vous avez
préparé un petit truc sur la télé là non
à écouter voilà je voulais parler d'aidé
de la télé des conneries qu'on passe à
la télé parce que tous les feuilletons
toute cette merde bon on le sait ça
mieux quelques films qui sont bien
qu'elle use dont celui que fait mon ami
et de munitions mais il ya beaucoup de
conneries quand même alors on peut pas
les regarder c'est à dire je voulais
dire ça c'est que les comités de lecture
depuis que le général massu est sorti de
sa vie c'est lui qui choisissait les
scénario tant à est alors de lui qu'il
est plus là il ya d'autres cons qui sont
là et qui choisit des conneries par
conséquent moi je fais pas de télé bon
deuxièmement je voulais parler de ça
puis finalement j'ai pensé que la guerre
de l'irak c'était très grave et que tous
les mecs qui parlent tous les spycker
qui parle ça je voudrais leur casser la
gueule parce que l'autre jour j'ai vu
une fille qui annonce et des victimes et
qui a rigolé après et alors les autres
s'ils se complaisent là dedans comme
s'il parlait de je ne sais pas de star
académie de réseau ce cas ils disent là
on en a tué trois les américains
avancent et c est en réalité nous on est
contre la guerre par conséquent pourquoi
on délaisse sa en se gargarisant ont
fait venir des mecs qui parlent des
généraux qui dit fallait faire ça les
américains adorent y est pire ça c'est
dégueulasse alors c'est mon coup de
gueule on tue des gens là-bas et tous et
qu on se gargarise était plein de pognon
l'attelage accepte pas mais c'est vrai
qu'il ya une complaisance des raisons il
ya une espèce de complaisance comme ça à
ressasser ça tire la genre et fort de
café jérôme j'écoute j'apprends
ouais tu apprends mais c'est bien mais
tout ça deviens ce que tu es et
merveilles claque homme sajjad j'adore
je sais pas depuis très petit je suis
très énervé par les gens qui privilégie
uniquement la jouissance et de
lampertheim bonne qu'au mondial j'aime
bien les choses un peu plus profond ce
qui fait de moi quelqu'un de malheureux
de pas adapté ouais voilà mais c'est
très bien j'assume tout à fait il a
cassé céline dion mais c'est bon ça
c'est pas difficile dans c'est pas dur
mais la façon dont tu l'as fait c'est
même moi j'étais assez mal à l'aise donc
alors à tenter quelque chose de très
très très difficile c'est un duplex avec
jérôme béglé qui est quelque part sur ce
plateau à l'eau jérôme est ce que vous
entendez ce fameux carry de très loin
mais je vous entends vous savez que l'un
des rendez vous phares de rdr gc le
débat hebdomadaire entre philippe tesson
jacques nerson est la question que tout
le monde se pose est ce qu'ils se
détestent vraiment oui alors on a réussi
rassemblés ici mais quand vous avez vu
côte à côte était pas possible ouais
sinon on risquait des pires du centre à
dolo ado est la réponse à cette question
est ce que c'est vraiment on commence
par philippe tesson bon j'ai beaucoup pv
jacques nerson j'aimais beaucoup de
jacques personne lorsqu'il était jeune
à ses débuts d'abord un chien a débuté
ici j'ai trouvé une sorte de modestie
une une douceur quelque chose assez
humain j'ai découvert que l'âge ne l'a
pas arrangé pour tout dire je crois que
c'est le problème
ce garçon vit très mal son évolution
dans le temps son évolution dans la vie
j'ai découvert que sa douceur était une
fausse douceur sa bienveillance une
fausse bienveillant sa bonhomie une
fausse bonhomie et je dois dire que nos
affrontements sont maintenant marquer
souci la sincérité la plus grande île
sont un nerf son zéro mais le match
retour maintenant une baie savez moi
j'ai eu philippe comme comme patron donc
élevée au quotidien de paris donc
évidemment comme tous les gens qui sont
passés par le quotidien de paris
j'ai certes un souvenir un peu mitigé de
philippe et j'étais très content de le
retrouver en position d'égalité de me
venger un peu de toutes les avanies que
j'avais subi
retournez-vous philippe est votre pire
qu'embrasser embrasse moi je pense que
vraiment il sera à vendre qui s'embrase
embrassé comme un viril embrassez-vous
sur la bouche je veux voir ça embrassez
vous sur la poche sur la bouche de son
fils dit il il faut pas beaucoup le prix
yemenia recensé un peu plus rares
jacques embrasser philips dans la bouche
s'il vous plaît il sera c'est vrai que
c'est vrai tout ça est une sinistre
comédie parce que j'aurai on annoncera
d'or au ca d'or dans la vie privée on
s'attend on s'adore vivent ensemble on
passait nos vacances le lundi soir ils
rentrent ensemble chez eux
que c'est pourquoi j'avais lyon sur la
bouche a fait il est en fait c'est très
bien mais voilà c'est tout ce que je
voulais après j'ai pu placer la suite de
cette spéciale millièmes toujours en
compagnie de michel serrault et de jean
pierre mocky plus jazzy et iegor gran
qui a donc gagné le prix rdr ger hayes
la favorita vous connaissez igor g il a
fait un livre extraordinaire c'est
l'histoire de deux ong qui s'affrontent
connaissez pas cette histoire je vais
vous raconter pendant la pub a plus
[Musique]
chers amis chers ennemis re re bonsoir
suite de cette spéciale millièmes avec
le best of des meilleures expressions
culinaire 2 françois simon alors
françois simon bailly les mosaïques et
bien entendu aussi dans la foi et dans
les restos et que sa petite caméra donc
jean-pierre vous savez le travail qui
fait c'est extraordinaire tarifs alors
il va dans les restos que sa petite
caméra vous à pishin les trucs en très
très gros plans pis saoulent avec ça
forçait t il et c'est extraordinaire ce
qui fait si tu avais créé jassim des
vraies révélations de la saison pour
nous busto fabrice bousteau bonsoir lui
bouge sur le collège a invité dans
l'émission y'a déjà l'année dernière à
bled avant mais françois simon c'est
très étonnant ce qui fait alors vous
êtes en quête de restaurants vous michel
en général je mange plus beaucoup et je
ma femme me fais à manger des dépouilles
il peut aller il peut aller chez vous
faites à domicile d'hérépian
il peut aller avec sa caméra chez madame
0 oui et puis la purée par exemple coûté
si c'est possible je n'aurais rien alors
attention j'arrive à l'improviste il
arrivait régulièrement elle vit dire
pascal 0 j'aime beaucoup
elle a beaucoup de qualités mais pour la
cuisine c'est nul voila alors si je vais
vous donner mon adresse et plus non mais
ça serait important addiction moi
j'aimerais bien aussi que tu viennes à
la maison comme ça pour un peu fliqué la
femme donc vous le connaissez oui dans
quelle dans quel resto vous allez vous
jean pierre anger et moi je vais chez
moi déjà parce que ça coûte rien et puis
je connais des endroits bien où on
achète des choses pas chères est bonne
ouais je travaille je travaille chez moi
comme cuisinier quelques fois et puis je
vais dans des restaurants chine toc mais
il y en a tellement qu'il faut les
choisir dans la chiasse et on n'est pas
prêt on regarde le travail de françois
simon
l'appétit des légumes la plupart du
temps ils sont ridiculisés
purée enrichi où ils sont écrasés on le
reconnaît même plus vient vraiment c'est
du poireau qu'à toute sa dignité c'est
important qu'on va voir ce que ça donne
mais je les sentiers du tout j'ai pu
travailler ses mots
bah c'est un pas sans âme quoi qui est
mort il respire tu m'aimes la croûte
ouvriers y signer molle mais réalisent
pas ou l'intérieur
sincèrement et dany saultain ce fromage
une très sale tête bon jambon industriel
ça avec se refait bleuté un peu mazout
et enfin une tête de pétrole vous savez
ce qui est bien ou à gratens et quand ça
gratte income la haie à côté puis
surtout quand il n'est pas un fils il
respire encore te dire qu il était frais
récemment et au fil des heures il s'est
pas passé comme ça vous voyez il encore
debout il a dès l'arrivée appelé en
pleurs ce qui est à l'intérieur c'est à
dire que chaque phrase et distingue
c'est pas un méli mélo voilà c'est
gratiné dans la mode est toujours des
gens qui ont des camps d expression
vocale existentielle problématique donc
ça y va ça ça s'exprime à des sautes
signifié
[Musique]
immédiatement son entrée en lice aux
dogues alors j'attends temps de sourire
de cheval ce que devient dans la tarte
aux pommes c'est le côté croustillant
c'est à dire que lorsqu'on met la
fourchette de suisse où est une ville
merveilleuse musique cristalline
voilà c'est parti
ok c'est vu bon c'est pas une raison
pour chaque année mais c'est vrai que ça
l'état ou à vue et alvéolées les trous
d'air on voit même qu'à des grains tout
ça c'est une usine glace bon ça a son
charme mais bon dans les glaces on aime
bien les jeunes surtout quand elles sont
fraîches et parfois de l'ananas pitt se
devait être monstrueux ça doit être
écoeurant toilettes chimiques
ça va la phase a vraiment gucci globe
mais elle est vraiment dégueulasse comme
on aime bien ça nous fait au final tout
ça bah écoute et on arrive avec l'e10
hook puis comment bien gaulée voyez 177
haut et il faut surtout pas oublier la
chambre quand on arrive à 808 euros
écoutez vous plaignez pas parce que ça
vous fait quasiment à l'oeil un piercing
gratuit de la langue et d'information de
l'estomac et la banque expose donc ça va
voilà c'était donc le travail de
françois simon alors pendant le magnéto
michel serrault lui demander s'il
cherchait le restaurant le meilleur ou
le plus dégueulasse
et c'est vrai qu'on a l'impression des
fois c'est tellement nul ce que vous
trouvez dans ses restaurants constamment
si vous le faites pas exprès
il ya quand même quelque chose qui est
assez assez désarmant dans la
gastronomie c'est qu'on a l'impression
que partout ces familles dès que par
tous et de bonheur que partout il ya des
génies or on s'aperçoit que la vie un
filtre tout c'est comme dans le cinéma
bahia régulièrement et pour notre plus
grande joie des navets des réseaux dans
le même domaine et c'est ça la vie c'est
totalement imprévisible c'est
contradictoire et c'est ça qui fait
qu'on va toujours voir un autre signe
toujours voir un autre restaurant parce
qu'on ne sait jamais ce qui va se passer
c'est ça qui est drôle c'est ça qui est
bien
moi j'ai gt gt thierry la semaine
dernière il a parlé de la table de
lucullus un restaurant à lui sinon c'est
un jeune mec sans formation départ hyper
cultivé qui fait une cuisine méga
expérimental si l'art contemporain au
maroc de la portion des lots qu'ils
s'occupent des arts contemporains mais
c'est ça qui nous l'a trouvé une cuisine
et c'est d'art contemporain et c'est une
vraie jouissance et c'est vrai que
d'ailleurs que le ce type c'est
important parce que ce que fait aussi
françois simon sait qui parle aussi des
découvreurs
qu'est ce que fait ce type la table de
curieuses il est contre les grands
d'aujourd'hui c'est-à-dire gagnaire en
faisant une cuisine beaucoup plus
expérimental et on peut bouffer a en
gros à 300 balles et on bouffe que des
poissons sauvages on bouffe d'aider des
anguilles gluante et c'est moi je trouve
une vraie expérience
alors ça peut sembler comme ça
complètement dégueulasse et alors il ya
une espèce de grande jouissance une
éjaculation d'essence qui apparaît comme
ça soudainement gala et sa merci
françois godard donc yade et à briscous
et jacques hull quand elle m'a vu mourir
à 1800 l'habitude parce qu'il faut voir
ce qui nous montre comme comme
expressions de l'art moderne donc tout
ça est bien dans tous les cas bravo
vraiment c'est très très bien ce que
vous faites si on avait un carnet d
adresses pour aller au plus dégueulasse
soc le resto le plus dégueulasse tu en
voilà certes le resto vraiment où il
faut envoyer son nom mais territoire et
souches pour envoyer mon pire ennemi
ça y est je laisse sur les champs
elysées et délices café à le restaurant
d'adriana karembeu et ça vous êtes sûr
de gagner à tous les coups
voilà c'est persiste et on signe même ce
soir dans une heure c'est encore même
niveau c'est voyez karembeu le cas des
jambes qu'il elle a des jambes qui lui a
glissé à peu près oui merci merci
fabrice bousteau merci françois simon
merci jean pierre mocky ce héros vous
rester avec moi
ehret suite cette spéciale millièmes
avec le best of de ne plus belles pages
le replay coup de coeur l'exploit ne pas
rater c'est bouleversant acheter gomez
et du bois c'est super bien c'est
peut-être mon coup de coeur du journal à
monsieur l'humanité moi je me souviens
je l' ai vu à cannes j'étais atterré jeu
les revues je voulais dit je suis né il
rejoint régime a tué d'un coup c'est un
film immense
il ya des plans à mourir sur ses fesses
il est beau comme un papier pas moisi
qui partirait en lambeaux sur le vieux
mais haut de votre petite chambre
d'enfant abandonné d'une tristesse
absolue c'est magnifique magnifique la
vengeance des petites que c'est un beau
délectable chacun ses paroles il faut
aller voir matthew barney parce que vous
détestiez vous aimiez pas passer sa 21e
chacun c'est marrant on fait attention à
ce que vous allez dire parce que la
dernière fois à merson avait émis
quelques doutes sur le précédent
spectacle de fabrice luchini ça nous
avait valu les foudres de fabrice donc
j'espère que vous avez aimé y aura pas
de foudre ah non ça me rassure j'ai
trouvé ça formidable
j'ai trouvé le petit nid fort bien alors
il ya isabelle carré on a vu un bel
arrêt nrj vous dire
eric besson il ya un moment dans le sens
mystique voire absurde
moi je succombe elle est vraiment elle
s'inscrit dans un registre et d'actrices
un combat doit pas l'équivalent en
france c'est à dire la fraîcheur la
lumière là la transparence
il est parti non mais c'est vrai chacun
c'est marrant je le dit les yeux dans
les yeux
chers amis téléspectateurs acheter gomez
et du bois voilà c'est vraiment énorme
l'adjectif étincelant semble avoir été
inventé pour décrire ce beau livre le
plus beau livre écrit en français depuis
ma naissance
la vraie poésie d'aujourd'hui c'est
gomez et du bois ces mecs là à quoi je
ne sais pas c'est du bois ça faisait
moins 15 autres vous n'allez pas parler
mais c'est pas fini
franchement je voulais en dire du mal
lire aussi je suis dit 'mon tiens qui
fait du sombre ait pas mal ça va être
ignoble
abbas est super bien chacun sait maroc
alors jérôme voilà votre fameux petit
protégé
je dois dire alors vous vous avez gomez
et du bois l'eau mais c'est du bois avec
lesquels vous nous casser les pieds
depuis d'avoir acheté gomez et du bois
c'est quand qu'on dit du mal on dit du
mal on dit du mal voilà c'était donc nos
coups de coeur comme on dit bêtement
général à la télévision nous on a dit
nos plus belles pages mais c'est pas
mieux c'est pas peur n'a pas de mot pour
ça tu puisses tu dis toi quand il ya un
truc que tu aime beaucoup
un coup de coeur c'est un peu ridicule
ça va se faire bonsoir zazie bonsoir à
l'ex niçois soir mais félicien sont
alors diego gran voilà et vladimir dunk
et donc le rédacteur en chef de cette
émission
alors on va commencer par vous vous avez
été quand même notre premier prix rive
droite rive gauche
est-ce que tu connais le bouc awendjé
zazie de iegor gran pas du tout alors
voilà il voulait que je fasse le pitch
sans gros s'ils s'appellent ong
et donc c'est l'histoire de deux
organisations humanitaires 10 ans qui
partage le même immeuble il y en a une
qui défend l'écologie l'autre qui défend
les enfants du tiers-monde les enfants
du tiers-monde ils se tirent des bourgs
dans cet immeuble pour une place de parc
et c'est terrible parce que c'est
tellement vrai malheureusement c'est
extraordinaire dont on a complètement
flashé sur le bouquin et on lui a donné
le prix en fin de l'année pour lui a pas
donné les gens ont voté pour le prix
rive droite rive gauche
et si on avait lundi dernier john
malkovich qui était notre invitée et qui
était jury du prix signer roman qui
était un prix pour l'adaptation du cadre
du festival de paris
vous n'avez pas eu et non et pourtant
malkovich été très chaud il était
président du prg y signer roman était
très chaud pour vous le donner mais
voilà oui c'est un prix où je suppose
les gens ne votent pas comme chez vous
ouais et alors le père de iegor gran ces
signes apps qui était un des premiers
refusent nique
c'est comme ça qu'on dit non c'est
plutôt un dissident a écrit un titre et
dissidences était un type qui s'est
dressé contre le régime communiste à
l'époque où ça existait encore moi j'ai
connu votre père et il est venu il est
fait d'abord six ans quand je crois en
sibérie et ensuite il est venu à paris
et voilà il y est gore ne savait pas on
a aimé son bouquin sans savoir qu'il
était le fils de daniel synapses qui
s'est quand même qui était un héros
contre l'époque c'étaient ses mavs en
brèche neft andropov non c'était près je
n'étais pas vraiment resserrer la vis
après khrouchtchev venir vous êtes
d'origine russe vous oublie donc vous
comprenez tout ça je comprends et puis
je comprends aussi que ce qu'il faut
dire une chose c'est que igor a choisi
de ne pas s'appeler signal ce qui passe
il en avait peut-être un peu marre qu'on
lui colle la rue situe dans la peau oui
moi je comprends ça c'est bien parce que
je suis d'origine russe et j'ai pas un
nom qui est véritablement russes et
celles que l'ont quand même et le ton
aux méthodes le ton la volga et c'est
quand même assez important parce que
comme vous dites si
si les gars étaient à payer gorce ignace
qui on lui aurait demandé d'écrire comme
dostoïevski on lui a demandé de deux de
danser comme serge lifar ou de parler de
rachmaninoff etc
et quand on est russe parfois on en a un
peu ras le bol ouais de toute cette
bande de loterie j'irai connaissent un
taux de la culture russe et donc on
aimerait tant en tant qu on oublie cette
rue située je trouve qu'il a c'est assez
courageux de sa part et en même temps je
trouve ça assez assez normal qu'il l'ait
fait parce que je comprends très bien
voyez vous c'est vos parents vos grands
parents qui s'en venait c'est mes grands
parents qui sont venus mais papa est
russe et la révolution fut la révolution
voilà voilà
c'est laid ce qu'on appelle les russes
blancs c'est dans les actes la
révolution s'est terminée ce thème vous
ai pas envie
messi mais j'y suis retourné souvent est
alors oui non c'est un pays auquel je
suis très très attaché je parle la
langue d'ailleurs avec igor en coulisses
on se parle en russie pourrait faire
l'état russe mais je crois que ça
reviendrait pas mal de monde
et puis on vient de dire qu'on voulait
échapper la russie tude alors on va
peut-être pas le faire maintenant poser
une question aux russes quand même pas
johan possible à dire j'ai compris ce
pas si beau mois c'était pas durer en
fait on est mexicain alors quasi on va
vous revoir parce que le 22 avril et un
cd qui s'appelle that is alive d'avancer
toujours le sens des titres
cette idée de me 17 partout c'est pas
grave j'ai trouvé ça et le dvd lui sort
le 29 avril chez paprec une semaine de
plus pour le fabriquer vous vous êtes en
concert le 17 juin au zénith comme
l'asie alors on vous a demandé vous
aussi de faire une petite liste de vos
oeuvres préférées alors en lit vous avez
choisi une petite robe de fête de
christian bobin ouais pourquoi j'ai le
bouquin dans ma poche peut vous lire un
extrait ouais ouais volonté sur
l'émission culturelle eh bien voilà il
est bien avec soi c'est en plus un
extrait de la préface donc ça n'a rien à
voir avec la
mais c'est un petit livre en fait j'ai
choisi ce livre parce que quand on
n'aime pas lire
c'est bien de d'appréhender la lecture
quand même et que voilà ce qui dit je
sais c'est court 1 il y à la main
blanche de ceux qui ont pour l'argent il
y à la main fine de ce qu'ils ont pour
le songe
il y à tous ceux qui n'ont pas demain
privé d'or privé d'encre c'est pour ça
qu'on écrit ce ne peut être que pour ça
et quand c'est pour autre chose c'est
sans intérêt pour aller des 1 vers les
autres pour en finir avec le
morcellement du monde pour en finir avec
le système des castes et enfin toucher
aux intouchables pour offrir un livre à
ce qu'ils ne liront jamais parfait alors
là je vais vous dire dans le studio
tout le monde ya eu un incident c'est la
première fois depuis le début de
l'émission début 1
tout le monde a écouté zadi lire
l'extrait de christian bobin une petite
robe de chute alors c'est pour ça alors
le film sait mais ce n'est pas un film
qui est sorti depuis dans les cinq
dernières années c'est johnny s'en
va-t-en guerre
johnny got his gun de dalton trois
peintres qui sentent bon alors ça j aime
quoi la mine on vous existez non donc
oui johnny s'en va-t-en guerre c'est
vachement bien mais c'est le mec dans le
voilà c'est juste après la première
sensation en fait j'ai choisi des choses
qui correspondent à des sensations qui
n'ont rien à voir avec des choses
intelligentes ou intellectuels s'étaient
qu'est ce qui fait que quelqu'un qui ne
nie pas ce va se mettre à lire d'un coup
qu'est ce qui fait que quelqu'un qui va
pas au cinéma ou qui va en faisant pif
paf où tes mains va pour d'autres
raisons
tony cotte disque j'avais prévu de dîner
avec des amis après j'ai pas pu ouais
donc ça m'a laissé les spectateurs donc
c'est l'histoire d'un soldat qui est
dans le coma il entend des sons ils
entendent ils voile très déjà voilà ça
va servir un peu
voilà d'essai pour la science pour les
poulains touchant la voix off tout le
temps voilà voix intérieure absolument
théâtre yasmina reza changer chanson
let's go à 2 to night blue n'a pas cessé
je suis tombé de temps en temps je vais
à la fnac que je fais des expéditions
punitives c'est-à-dire j'achète les
choses que j'aime
et puis j'achète des trucs parce que la
pochette est belle de temps en temps
c'est un fiasco parce que la musique à
l'intérieur c'est que sincèrement n'a
rien à vrai que la pochette et de temps
en temps j'ai acheté donc ce groupe blue
nile inconnu au bataillon qui saura
c'est un groupe anglais qui sera un
album tous les cinq ans et je suis tombé
sur cette chanson et j'avais envie dans
l'introduction d'aller danser dans la
2ème d'embrasser en amoureux dans la
troisième
d'éclater en sanglot dans la quatrième
tout ça en cinq minutes et j'ai aimé
sans comprendre ce qu'ils disaient j'ai
appris compris que le texte était très
beau ce qui est pour moi la musique
c'est à dire que moi je me lutte à
chaque fois que j'écris avec des jeux
doit passer au sens des mots je suis
dans je suis réductrice à dire que la
sensation que j'ai eues en composant est
beaucoup plus forte que le sens du mot
et cette chanson puisque c'était
l'anglais donc j'avais une permission à
ne pas comprendre ma provoqué tout un
tas d'émotions sans avoir besoin de
mettre un mot dessus mais c'est ce que
j'aime dans cette émission en fait c'est
que depuis cinq ans je suis payé pour
cultiver site asiatique par rapport aux
riches d'un problème
le premier joue dans cette émission
c'est qu'à la fin j'étais vachement je
sais pas si c'est très riche
je sais pas si je vais être très
richement tous les cas je serais
extrêmement cultivé tout aujourd'hui
alors j'ai appris donc voilà let's go to
night mais ça y va jamais lâcheté par
exemple il le dit pas il fait semblant
la télé non non non je sais même pas ce
que c'est j'avoue je sais d anglais 6 à
offrir est atteint on connait c'est ça
non bah lui connaît pas
non non mais là j'y vais ce soir demain
après demain c'est déjà ça il fait des
avantages
j'ai pas le temps je vais faire le clown
comment ça va très bien très bien vous
trouvé votre place petit à petit dans
l'émission oui oui j'ai fait décrochent
des crocs-en-jambe à deux trois copains
lanouaille et je trouve ça va ça va bien
très bien
c'est vraiment sympa merci zazie merci
alex merci de la demir y accorde tant
pis pour le prix roman signer roman mais
bon on va ça va changer les deux déjà
ouais franchement on petit fier mais ça
reste un petit peu oui qu'il faut dire
c'est qu'il aurait quand même mérité
parce qu'elles sont son livre est
vraiment scénaristiquement c'est un
livre très très gelé la première fois
qu'on leur sujet certains super scénario
de film il l'aurait mérité s'il vient
joyce carol pauwels héros cherche du
travail
michel serrault capable de jouer
n'importe quoi enfin ça c'est vrai il a
prouvé à plusieurs personnages à double
fond à double tranchant médiation bien
alors comme c'est la veille on est le 31
mars et la veille du 1er avril
on va voir un best-of d'un numéro qu'on
avait fait pour le 1er avril de l'année
dernière le 1er avril 2002 replay guie
guie vous êtes prêt à retirer ce que
vous avez dit à mon sujet dans le nouvel
observateur par exemple mais pas
toujours et je ne retire en rien mais
qui
quoi c'est quoi aujourd'hui il avait
enfin on avait dit que joe biden a on
avait dit qu'aujourd'hui on va coûter
moi non plus alors d'accord mais moi je
retire en rien sa vaste elle coupe la
communication dans l'émission vous avez
pris la tête avec ce bouquin
maintenant c'est le plateau ont
recommencé aussi d'accéder aux grandes
après une chance sur 116 50 émissions et
c'est la première fois qu'ils se cassent
des plateaux jeune que moi car mu fait
des paiements on est d'accord je lis
doit être publiée m montrer à la télé on
doit en débattre et les visas bête
elisabeth et vous êtes là comme de
réactionnaire que vous qui puissiez de
ramener sur la terre parce que toute
façon et vous je trouve à lausanne n'a
rien à voir moi je vais aller voir ce
qui se passe je comprends pas levé tous
les cas bravo batterie je félicite et
vous êtes arrivé à futuna terrain
meurtriers sur un beau buzz puisque je
ne peux pas en parler donc je me bats
aussi un droit maintenant je me retrouve
tout seul comme un con
moi je vais aller les chercher
1er avril poisson d'avril voilà c'était
donc l'émission du 1er avril de l'année
dernière merci à tous d'avoir été avec
nous pour 7 millièmes
mille merci à notre pléiade d'invités
michel serrault le parrain historique
des premières adepte de nos dérives sur
les deux rives daniel auteuil claude
berri gendarmes sans réelle dans bâle
andré dussollier mélanie tout et axelle
laffont jean pierre mocky zazie igor
gran mille merci à mon complice stéphane
tillement à la production 1000mercis
organisateurs tristan carné fait qu'on a
comme réalisateur tristan carné que
c'est le neveu de marcel carné de la
connerie s'y attendait c'est pas de la
merde
mille merci donc à emmanuel père
j'aurais hélène grémillon père en gère
le grand qui ont préparé les best of de
cette émission
mille merci annie benayoun eric mas
tatania rizk isabelle gélinet solène
cela de l'est n'aurait les pavés sur les
ménages et à toute l'équipe technique
mille merci à l'auteur alain gourmand et
surtout mille mercis à la chaîne paris
première qui est une chaîne commerciale
et qui fait de la culture alors que
normalement ça se mettait au service
public de le faire donc bravo à paris
première merci en tous les cas valérie
bernis stéphane quéré jacques expert
analyse moutons qui est pas mal
c'est aller bien surtout que tu es trop
jeune et naïve merci ma chérie d'avoir
eu la bonne idée d'imposer la tête
un grand rendez vous hri paris première
a imposé un grand rendez vous culturel
quotidien fait cette édition spéciale
millièmes chers amis chers ennemis au
revoir à demain 19 15 pour l'ami les 1e
r d hergé toute l'actualité culturelle
en quart du serbe invaincu et puis
rendez vous pour la michel serrault pour
la 2000e le j'espère bien si tout va
bien quand tout ira bien
inch'allah punk hull
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
l'ina l'habitude abonnez vous il m'était
impossible eux